privatize everything what they'll see
wants to do it
prices breakers how about Nick Gillespie
and I'm the editor-in-chief of Reason TV
and reason.com
drew and reason TV put a little series
out and we all watched it some people
reported on it and I wrote a letter
saying if you'd like to come and have a
little dialogue with your Cleveland City
Council we'd like to offer that to you
and you said yes I sell breakfasts and
we're here today you did the reason
program Reason Foundation video and what
I'm saying is we looked at this and you
you you're whacked is pretty good it
wasn't meant to be a love letter was
meant to be a hey something's wrong yeah
and it was like an and it was meant
honestly it was actually meant to not a
software problem but to start a
discussion just like we're having right
now and so I appreciate though the fact
that you invited us to come here and
speak to you and talk to you because
that's what it's all about people don't
talk nothing gets done you know there's
a perception that things don't work in
this city and I think a lot of that is
just perception perpetuated by the media
and by others and know Cleveland's been
a big joke for a long time and I think
we we vidiian work they've been making
jokes about Cleveland for a long time
Cleveland has not been a joke Cleveland
has many good things going on but it is
in a long-term economic decline that has
reached a crisis situation as it had
been as high as the seventh largest city
in the country it's now the 41st largest
it has less than half the number of
people it had 1950 it lost 10% of its
population in the decade of the
thousands it has lost many of its it's
jobs that are not coming back I mean
this is something that needs to be
addressed this is a great city we have
cultural institutions second to none we
have a lakefront we have the world
leave an orchestral best in the world we
have that nobody else has have there
been mad bad decisions made in the city
you're doggone right you're looking at
one I'm right over here a stadium on the
lakefront but no retractable roof on it
that the only thing in there is seagulls
and snow in the wintertime okay you know
when I love the Cavs and I like to in
Gilbert I've met him he's a nice guy but
you know he can afford his own stadium
thank you three quarters of the schools
in the Cleveland Public School System
are an academic watch or emergency which
are the worst categories that the state
has how do you address that I totally
agree with you that competition and
education is something that should be
tried
I was anti voucher guy I mean many years
ago I have changed on that issue the
solution we brought up in the video that
I like better and I thought that that's
the the best school idea I've heard of
all the school ideas is the backpack
funding where every school public and
private charter school in public school
has to compete for every student and
that the money stays with a student I
think the goal for Cleveland should be
to be the number one business friendly
city in the country I was reading in the
New York Times three days ago the mayor
of New York City there are a billion
dollars in tourism
although they put aside twenty two
million dollars fun for businesses to
develop in his city and technology they
may be City Wireless open the city up
for technology I think that if we move
in that direction also to give business
supports we can't do 22 million or
whatever so that we can reach out to
businesses just to let them know that
our culture has changed the business any
business that's telling you I'm only
going to not only going to set up shop
here if you give me a tax break for the
first five years in a couple you know
and a hundred thousand dollars in my
pocket they either can't make it on
their own or they're gonna bolt as soon
as you stop paying them the bigger
so that's the wrong way to do if I would
tell those guys to see you later and
then with the door head I'm gonna win it
shouldn't be a struggle and you
shouldn't have to go through a lot of
paperwork and headache to start a
business in Cleveland and I think a lot
of times when people think of Cleveland
they think oh my god I don't want to put
up with that when I want to start a
business here there's a gentleman in the
city of Cleveland who was a very
successful business person who now works
running a non-profit he owns a business
in the city right on 69th in Carnegie
and he wants to put in a twenty thousand
dollar sign okay because he's trying to
bring up his business he applied for a
variance to do it that's what he says he
says if we have to go I'm just no read
it goes for each to it if we have to go
to the zone and review board I
understand it it may take 60 days for
approval that is simply too long the
summer will be over the carwash will
have lost more money this is the kind of
stuff that hurts Cleveland and puts
people out of business it's just
ridiculous let me put some context to
this answer if you apply for a sign
that's within our regulation it would
take nowhere between three to five days
to get assignments within the
regulations if it's outside the
regulations that's a needs to be 4 foot
by 8 foot the biggest sign no more than
two or three colleges kind of one
scenario if you want to go to 10 by 10
and put up a little bit higher than have
10 colors on it you have to get approval
to go outside doesn't matter how many
colors are on I'm just that it's one of
the regulations we have that's we get
rid of it got it the current set up a if
we have right now
if bureaucracies not working they call
upon us and we try to help guide them
through the red tape the perfect world
the red tapes all gone and we're doing
our legislative responsibilities and
trying to create the laws that okay or
restructure or restructure the laws that
are hampering us the City Planning
chairperson is next to me she's on the
City Planning Commission and we as the
city are looking at a comprehensive
overhaul not elimination of our planning
codes but a comprehensive overhaul
it's kind of year and a half we've been
building it through we haven't
recommended changes yet I recommend
going to a councilman who might be able
to speed that up it's not about the
store in the corner it's not about the
zoning it's about disinvestment in our
city
I'm not politically correct so I'm not
gonna keep it has grabbed his over as of
this line of questioning okay go ahead
just on the northeast side Fisher bodyto
morick a blue pillar Sylvania Cyril
copper Viking steel and I can go on they
locate it they moved out of the city
cleave and a lot of them are short so
they could they could deal with people
making five bucks an hour in China I
know you can't compete with five dollar
wages with you know low-income waiters
in third world countries
and that's gonna be a sad fact of life
for us for a long time but you can't
compete on a lot of other things why not
pick the pick the most depressed area in
Cleveland however you want to define
that and just so you know what we're
gonna suspend normal regulations for X Y
or Z period see what happens
you want to help Cleveland bring the
prices bring price right on the show I
put on a road when I when I first I'll
take a quick story when I first was
offered the job as the host the very
very very first meeting I had with CBS
they told me hey guess what we're
getting ready to travel to show there we
go
and I said well that's great because the
first place we should take it is
Cleveland five months later they had a
meeting and they decided it was too
expensive to move the show shut down
production the request to bring the
prices right to Cleveland and I don't
mean to be overly kind of argumentative
that is the problem
no you know what the prices right is not
coming here at the Jersey Shore is not
coming here you know car manufacturing
not coming back here what Cleveland has
to do is say okay what can we bring to
the world not what the world can bring
to us and I suspect that when that
mindset is gone it will be six months
into a great long lift recovery of
Cleveland I love the West Side Market
don't get me wrong but it's only open
it's only open four days a week
it's not open that many hours my idea is
to sell it to somebody who knows how to
manage a market if I wanted to be mean
about it I would open a market right
next door to the West Side Market and
put you out of business
there are people who argue that we
should privatize our parks let the
private sector run our parts because why
are we in the business of cutting grass
and watching trees and all that we can
take that argument to a point that all
we do is arrest folks take pick up trash
and make sure the rules don't have to
meet potholes but I will more
believability and what government can do
for change it's just my philosophy and
we'll agree to disagree I don't envy
anybody here at the table a lot of work
to do and totally it's a you know
changing prices right from a place that
gave away grandfather clocks you know
every day to modern you know the first
year I took over prices right it was the
first year they had the theme song and
stereo no way anytime you want to come
and visit Cowell would I'll give you a
grand tour but the only one stipulation
you can't wear that jacket you know I've
been in this city for a long time while
you've been in public office
you've always been a snappy dresser and
we have the same exact cufflinks how
about that
that I was just gonna say how about that
and I think I bet you would look great
in this jacket
meeting adjourned
thanks everybody
you